ben shapiro is here to talk about that
also the president's promise to build a
wall and developments in that and a
surprise announcement as well Ben good
to see you good evening thanks for
having me so your thoughts it was hard
to listen to those I wish we didn't run
it for so long actually but it's hard to
listen to them what are your thoughts on
on what's going on in America when
that's the way that people voice their
desire to their senator I mean obviously
people are more interested in basically
venting their feelings than they are and
actually effectuating change that
they're much more interested in making
themselves heard than in actually
getting other people to listen to them
and that there's an obvious irony to all
of these people calling up Susan Collins
and basically slandering her as in in
every conceivable way a feckless woman
using sexist slurs to to rip her for
supposedly being too sexist to listen to
Christine blazing the Cavanaugh hearings
I mean all of it is is absurd but it
speaks to I think a rising rage that
Americans are feeling across the aisle
and I think that that goes to a lack of
social fabric I think that we are we're
coming apart at the seams in a lot of
ways and we're filling that with anger
and political tribalism you know it was
also pointed out today by the Senate
ethics complaint the Phantoms are the
foundation for accountability and civic
trust it's called fact and they look at
the least ethical behavior that happens
on the hill and they claimed according
to their look at all of this that the
two least ethical members of the Senate
were senators Warren and Harris who both
sent campaign fundraising emails before
the Senate vote on the Supreme Court
Justice Brett Kavanaugh specifically
those emails stated their official role
and positions in the ongoing
confirmation process and then they said
donate now and contribute which is
against the rules Ben yeah I mean and
it's plainly morally disgusting as well
I mean you're in the middle of a
contentious hearing over whether a crime
did or did not happen years ago and
you're sending out fundraisers on your
own behalf in the middle of that even as
Senator Kamala Harris for example was
going out there and making completely
unwarranted charges about Judge
Cavanaugh it really was an astonishing
display the politics has become
bloodsport for for so many people these
days including the people who are in
Congress
and let's be frank about this Kamala
Harris and Elizabeth Warren we're doing
this because they're both running for
president in 2020 it had nothing to do
with principle it had nothing to do with
decency it had nothing to do with due
process it was a disgusting display from
beginning to end and Claire McCaskill
says she thinks it's one of the reasons
that she lost her race the way that her
party handled that whole process I want
to get your thoughts on the wall because
obviously this is central to what the
president ran on securing the border and
at this point we're hearing moments ago
that it sounds like from Senator Shelby
basically they've reached to kick the
can down the road agreement I know
that's a real shock so it looks like
they're gonna deal with funding the
government in the new year that's the
big game there was to surprise it yeah
it always tends to be a bluff when
people talk government shutdown what's
kind of shocking about this is the Chuck
Schumer tried this exact same tactic
back in January 2018 and it went so
badly for him that he ended up backing
off it seems to me that if the president
really wanted to press the issue there
were ways for him to press the issue
right here especially given the fact
that he's not going to get another shot
at this I mean once the Democrats are in
charge of the house then the chances
that he gets anything remotely
resembling anything like border funding
completely dissipate especially in the
midst of investigations they're sure to
launch against him and the president I
think should have taken a stronger
position here I think that his
supporters have a right to be upset with
that the wall has not been built it
doesn't look like the wall is going to
be built and all of the promises
notwithstanding if the president doesn't
take some pretty dramatic action on that
this was his number one campaign promise
that it has not happened it has not
materialized and you pointed out on your
podcast today that it's interesting that
he is allowing the wall as he envisioned
it to slip away and I think you know in
a perfect world which I just discussed
with Chris Koos there is border security
there securing the border and I think
that they really agree on it more than
they disagree on it and maybe we will
get somewhere on that but you find it
ironic that they are passing this
criminal justice reform and that the
president was you know very big on law
enforcement and law and order but this
is what he is in foot in favor of I mean
it's definitely interesting at the same
time we're talking about not getting the
funding for a border wall we're talking
about passing a criminal justice reform
which I mean at the very least is
controversial in how many criminals it's
going to end up letting out of prison
whether or not those people end up being
safe on the streets is actually an open
question and a matter of open debate
inside the Republican caucus
it's definitely a bizarre move by
President Trump maybe he's trying to
reach out to the middle in preparation
for 2020 or maybe this is just
incoherence whatever it is I think the
president he's been fond of using the
bully pulpit in the past for particular
things he cares about it seems to me
that if he cares about the wall if he
cares about border security if he cares
about law and order then this would be a
great time for him to get on the stump
and talk about it well you want to get
on the stump and talk about something
and you have a big announcement so I
took tell us what what you're rolling
out tonight
yeah so coming out in March we have a
brand new book it's called the right
side of history they're really excited
to share the cover with you it's I think
a really important book it really is
about the hole in our heart that's been
left by the abandonment of
judeo-christian values as well as the
basic concepts of reason in modern
America and how we're filling that with
rage and anger and tribalism and how we
really need to create a new social
fabric built around the eternal
principles that are enshrined in the
Constitution but have roots that are
thousands of years older than that how
do you get them back well I think the
way you get them back is first by
addressing the lack of them you know we
are not living in a society that is
grounded in in a moral vision and if we
don't go back to the basics if we don't
relearn our Bible if we don't relearn
our Aristotle if you don't relearn our
Federalist Papers then we are basically
taking all of the gains of Western
civilization without understanding how
we came to this point in the first place
and then we're ripping away the roots of
the tree that we are standing on a
branch of I mean you do that the tree is
going to topple and that's what we're
seeing happening right now so how you
know you're a dad how do you try to do
that with your children I mean first of
all I I inculcate them certain basic
values they are made in God's image
they're unique individuals made in God's
image that they have the capacity to
reason and that the best way to work in
the world is to work through that reason
in trying to interpret a predictable
universe that you can understand that
you have the capacity to get together
with others and make a difference but
you're never allowed to force your views
on other people these used to be basic
American principles and if we don't
inculcate them in our kids from the time
that they are born and then enrich them
with that continuing message over time
then everything starts to fall apart we
lose what bound us together in the first
place and thanks we'll talk to you soon
good to have you tonight so much